poem sister stacy ann we're gonna move
right along with our program today and
we will be
favored by a special piece from brother
robinson altino and let me just say a
little bit about him
today we have virtuoso pianist robinson
altino
ministering amazing grace and beyond
being
skillful on the piano hosting concert at
concerts at lincoln center merkin hall
in carnegie hall
with his brother nerva altino and
graduating with a master's degree from
manhattan school of music
brother altino is a very humble and
spiritual
man of god he is a husband and
a father and he is the one that
introduced me to elder randy skeet a
couple
years ago so please give brother altino
a warm virtual welcome
so
[Music]
hello
so
[Music]
amazing if this is how music can
sound on earth imagine when we get to
heaven and when god creates
this new earth oh we will have
such rich and powerful music thank you
brother altino
for the ministration of that song
amazing grace and you know we'll be
talking about the sabbath which is in
the heart of god's law
and without the law there is no amazing
grace so thank you
for that peace now we will be
transitioning
into the q a segment of our discussion
and we are
joined by international speaker elder
randy skeet
he too was the husband and humble man of
god he is a graduate of oakwood
university
and also of the seventh-day adventist
theological seminary at
andrews university where he studied for
the ministry
and as he would say i ask that you pray
god puts his words
in his mouth listen be reverent and
think
as he speaks please welcome elder
randy skeet
okay elder skeet you can unmute yourself
uh is it possible to imbue him denisha
no i can't i cannot um i mean i can only
there we go there we go all right there
we are yeah
worked out god is good all the time
psalm 100 verse 5 lord is good
and this is absolutely true thank you
very much this is the nisha for the
invitation
to be a part of this presentation on the
subject that has
100 percent relevance particularly in
these last days
and we know as a people of prophecy that
the sabbath will be the issue
in the last days because it will allow
people to express
allegiance to god or allegiance to the
enemy
we know a law is coming that will make
sunday the day of worship officially
then people will have to make a choice
as the sabbath was the test for the
israelites coming into the wilderness
so will it be the test for god's people
before he enter that great
canaan land and so it's a very very
significant subject
and i thank you for allowing me to be a
part of it and may the lord's holy
spirit of truth
guide all of our minds that all that we
say
may be an expression of the truth
because only truth
sanctifies not opinion let me offer word
of prayer and then i'll take the
questions father in heaven
thank you lord for the words of christ
in john 16
13 albeit when he the spirit of truth is
come
he will guide you into all truth father
in the name of jesus
guide us into that truth forgive our
sins because sins interfere with the
comprehension of truth
cleanse our hearts i pray particularly
me give me
simple language that i may present your
words in a manner acceptable to all of
all ages i pray in jesus name
amen amen amen thank you for that
prayer elder skeet and pray lude our
first question is
what is the sabbath it's origins and
purpose and you can take it one at a
time
yes the sabbath can be viewed as a
principle and as a day
the sabbath day originated in eden
the sabbath principle has always existed
let me say that again
the sabbath day because the bible says
in genesis 1
5 and the evening and morning were the
first day so we have
days as units of time introduced when
god made
the heaven the earth and the heavens
associated with our earth
but the principle of the sabbath which
is the recognition of who god is
and the sense of dependence upon that
has
always existed and so the sabbath day
began in the garden of eden but the
sabbath
principle has always existed which is
total dependence on god
recognizing him as the source of life
and the one who maintains
and sustains so the origin of the day
is back to eden but the principle
is all the way back and we cannot date
it
that's the quest the answer to question
one the sabbath is a day of worship
when you do no work according to the
fourth commandment it is set aside to
contemplate creation but even more so
the creator who of course is jesus
christ
creating at the behest of the father it
is a day
to honor god without the destruction of
work or secular activities
to focus and concentrate on god to stop
all that we do that is required to make
a living
and to keep our eyes on the person who
really
is the source of our living it's a day
of rest
for the believers for the unbelievers
for the land
there's a sabbath for the land once
every 50 years once every seven years
and there's also a rest from from death
so the sabbath has several levels
agricultural personal spiritual at every
level
there's the concept of rest but we're
dealing with the weekly rest which is
the seventh day
again the day goes back to eden but the
principle goes way back
way back into eternity that we cannot
even imagine
so that's the answer to question one
is there question two i'm sure there is
denisha we can't hear you tanisha
okay thank you very much for that
question two is when
god rested on the sabbath in genesis
chapter two verses one to three
how can we be sure that was a command
for all creatures to rest because the
wording is almost is almost precisely
uh re reproduced in the fourth command
if you read genesis chapter 2 verses 1
to 3
and i'm reading from the king james
version the bible says thus the heavens
and the earth were finished
and all the hostile family and on the
seventh day
god ended his work which he had made and
he rested on the seventh day from all
his work which he had made
and god blessed the day and sanctified
it
because that in it he had rested from
all his work
which god created and made now you keep
that in mind
and you listen to the fourth commandment
exodus 28-11
remember the sabbath day to keep it holy
six days shalt thou labor
and do all thy work but the seventh day
is the sabbath of the lord thy god
in it thou shalt not do any work thou
nor thy son nor thy daughter thy man's
servant of thy maidservant of thy cattle
or thy stranger that is within thy gates
now listen to verse 11
for in six days the lord made heaven and
earth the sea and all that in them is
and rested the seventh day wherefore the
lord blessed the sabbath day and
hallowed it
verse 11 of exodus 20 is just simply
a rewarding of verses 2 and 3 of genesis
chapter 2 and so that when you add one
to the other because the bible must
must be studied here a little very
little
when you look at those two verses one
next to the other of those two passages
we see clearly that what is commanded
next to 20
was required in genesis chapter 2
when god uh when we read the information
about the blessing of that holy day all
the commandments go together
that's the teaching of the half-brother
of jesus james
in james chapter two verse eight if ye
keep the royal law according to the
commandment thou shalt love thy neighbor
as thyself
he do well but if we have respective
persons of two persons
he commits sin and are convinced of the
law as transgressors
for whosoever shall keep the whole law
and yet offend in one point he's guilty
of all
now he goes on to say for he that said
do not commit adultery
said also do not kill now
cain killed he committed he broke the
law because that commandment existed way
back then
but they all go together and where they
can get thou shalt not kill
well the law has always existed the
bible says
sin is the transgression of the law
first john 3
verse 8 tells us he that committed sin
is of the devil
for the devil sinneth from the beginning
how did the devil sin
because he broke the law of god if you
read romans 3 20
romans 4 15 romans 5 12 and 13 they tell
us clearly
without law there is no sin so the fact
that adam sinned
meant there was a law and the law as
given on sinai
are these ten laws that express the
principles of love for god
and love for our fellow man so the
sabbath commandment existed
when adam and eve were made and was
required of them by the way
when god gave it to adam and eve he gave
it to the entire population of the world
there were just two but they were the
entire population of the world
and of course they passed it on to the
offspring and the offspring to their
offspring
god's law has always been required if
you read psalm 103 verse 20 the bible
says
bless the lord ye his angels that excel
in strength
that do his commandments heartening
under the voice of his word
the commandments of god are observed
even
by the angels which means observance of
god's law
predicted the creation of this earth
god's law has always been there
adam and eve were required to observe it
and we're still required today
someone said either you are my sister
who are the poem isaiah 66 23
and it shall come to pass this from one
new moon to another
and from one sabbath to another shall
all flesh come to worship before me
and so it has always been it is and it
will always be
amen amen thank you so much
for for making that point as well that
the
the law the ten commandments have
existed from the beginning of creation
before creation because this government
is governed by his law
that's right i'm gonna transition i'm
gonna add brother
anthony ralph on to acts the next set of
couple questions so that i can monitor
monitor the chat and see what everyone
is saying so i'll be hopping off for a
bit
okay thank you very much pastor randy
skate for the first two questions now
we'll have the third
the fourth and the fifth how can we be
sure
that saturday is the seventh day god
rested on in creation
in fact it's a three-point question
three-part question was the sabbath done
away with
how do we reconcile paul's book and the
sabbath keeping see colossians 2 16
all right so how do we know that
the seventh day was the day on which god
rested god has never
left himself without witness to the
truth never
let me give you the most obvious uh
defense of the seven-day sabbath
there is an entire nation on the face of
the earth
that has kept the center of the sabbath
for thousands of years
actually the law was given directly to
them that there might be custodians to
give it to other people
i'm referring to the jewish nation and
they
know that the sabbath is the seventh day
from sunset on friday
to censored on saturday there's no
argument that can overthrow that now
let's use some common sense and some
honesty the christian world celebrates
easter
on the first day of the week sunday
because the whole christian world knows
christ rose on the first day so easter
is not celebrated on monday
or on saturday on wednesday it is
celebrated
on sunday the day on which christ rose
the christian world also regards this
thing called good friday
the day on which jesus died then the
simple question is
what is the day that lies between the
two and that day
is saturday the seventh day sabbath it
is you know this issue of the sabbath is
not a difficult one it just requires
simple honesty
and humility it is not a difficult task
to identify the day of rest people say
the calendar was changed the calendar
was not changed in the sense
that the order of the days were changed
that has remained
sunday to saturday from the memorial and
so the seventh
day on which god rested was the seventh
day of the week
the one he requires of us to observe
and on which we should avoid work now
the third part of the question was
was the sabbath done away with no
you see god's law is eternal his sabbath
has not been done away with
now attempts have been made with some
success
to institute a different day of worship
for reasons not connected to
righteousness let me say that again
righteousness
we have the popular day of worship in
christianity as
sunday this has no bible basis
whatsoever
but this change was predicted in daniel
7 25
speaking of the little horn which is
identified as the the roman church
by not only adventists but for hundreds
of years the little horn
has been identified at the roman power
the roman church now
the bible says of that power and it
shall speak great words against the most
high
daniel 7 25 and shall wear out the sins
of the most high
and think to change times and laws
now think to change because this
so-called change
is not recognized by heaven so they
shall think
to change times and laws what do you
understand by times and lost
well times the sabbath for them
has moved from saturday to sunday that's
a change in time
think to change times and laws now the
second commandment does not exist
in the catholic catechism it is taken
out because it forbids the worship of
images
and so we have think to change times and
laws
but no human being can do that because
the bible says in daniel 2 21
he removes this king said of the kings
he changes the times and the seasons
it is god who can do that not a man uh
in james chapter 4 verse 12 there is one
lawgiver not two the bible says there's
one lawgiver who is able to save and to
destroy
that lawgiver is christ the father and
the father
now any attempt made by a human entity
is not recognized by heavens so yes
attempts were made and most of the
christian world observes that they
enacted by human beings not by god
as far back as a 321 a.d the count
the the the emperor constantine who
supposedly got converted to christianity
he issued an edict in 321 at the
march of 321 on the venerable day of the
sun
let magistrates and those living in the
cities rest
constantine passed that law but he
allowed those in the country to continue
to work the farms
because people have to eat in 3 64 i
believe it is the council of laodicea
there were 50 cannons or laws that were
enacted at that council
which went between 363-6364
law number 29 says no one shall
do the eyes on sunday
or on sabbath on saturday instead they
should honor the lord's day which they
call
sunday so there was a law that forbid
that made illegal the observance of the
sabbath
not by god but by the early church that
had drifted
from the standards of right and wrong
and so the change to sunday was not
made by god it was made by man
and we're told by in acts 5 29 we ought
to obey god
rather than man by the way the acid test
that's coming upon us
will be this same very test shall we
keep the seventh-day sabbath of god
on the first day of the week which shall
be enacted by
secular powers so attempts have been
made to change today
millions of people follow the results of
human devising
but god has never changed his day as a
matter of fact
when jesus was discussing the signs of
his second coming
and of the time of trouble which would
befall the jews in his day
a few decades after he died jesus warned
them in matthew 24
28 let not your flight be on the sabbath
in the winter or on the sabbath
because he still expected them to keep
the sabbath
john the apostle john who lived the
longest of all the twelve
he died about a hundred six seventy
years after jesus
died and went back to heaven that's when
the apostle john died
he wrote in 1st john chapter 5 verse 3
that keeping god's commandments is the
expression of love
it is one of the themes of his book both
his gospel and his epistles
revelation chapter 22 verse 14 the very
last book of the bible blessed are they
that do his commandments
how can you do something that's done
away with and so the sabbath has not
been done away with
but human beings under the impetus of
satanic powers
and i cannot be pleasant about this
under the impetus
of satanic forces have passed human laws
that most people follow but god's
sabbath
is still the seventh day of the week
and that has not changed amen now thank
you very much
how do we reconcile paul's writings of
the sabbath
well paul is a defender of the sabbath
paul
is a defender of the law paul writes
in romans 7 from verse 7. what shall we
say then
is the law sin god forbid now if the law
isn't sin then it's righteousness
because the object of sin is
righteousness
is the law sin god forbid nay i
had not known sin but by the law for i
had not known
lust except the law had said thou shalt
not covet what is paul saying
the only way i knew what was wrong
was because there is a law in romans 3
31 paul writes do we then make floyd the
law through faith
may we establish the law paul writes in
first corinthians 7 19
circumcision is nothing and
uncircumcision is nothing
but the keeping of the commandments of
god now this is an astonishing statement
for a jew to say
circumcision is nothing because
circumcision was used just that word was
used
to refer to the entire jewish system as
a matter of fact
many non-jews non-jews were frequently
called the uncircumcised
and jews were called the circumcision
paul says
circumcision is nothing uncircumcision
is nothing
what counts is keeping the commandments
of god
then people argue many christians argue
well we are new testament christians
we don't have to keep the law the law
was nailed on the cross
what did god do in the new covenant we
are new covenant christians
he writes the law in the heart of a
person that's what is done in the new
covenant
it does not destroy the law it removes
the law from stone
is placed in the heart that is what is
done under the new covenant
so those who say we are new covenant
christians are not making sense
a new covenant christian his or her
greatest joy will be obey god
because under that covenant the law is
placed
in the heart of a person you read that
in jeremiah 31 33
hebrews 8 10 and hebrews 10 16.
all right i think i covered that next
question
and by the way thank you very much i ask
very politely i keep hearing voices
please mute your might we're dealing
with the law of god which means
obedience
please mute your might it is not that
difficult to do that please let's have
order
mute your might thank you and god bless
you yes my good brother
amen thank you very much for that uh for
the answer we now have the fourth
question
has there been an attempt to get rid of
the sabbath
if so what was it was it prophesying
well i dealt with that i just believe
that i was thinking about that yes
and all the way back to instantaneous
321 and the
the council of laodicea in 364 where a
law was passed
making it illegal to keep the sabbath
but allowing
sunday as a day of rest and that law
also says anyone found keeping a sabbath
will be shut out of christ it is amazing
that
men say or people say disobeying god
is life whereas god says disobey me is
death
it is an amazing thing that people were
condemned for keeping the sabbath even
though god pronounces a blessing
for observing his day yes attempts were
made there wouldn't
these attempts did not change god's law
in heaven let me just say
this god came
down from heaven to earth on sinai with
his son
and spoke within commands they came from
up down any change
must come from up down you cannot change
it from down
and send the change up i hope you
understand what i'm trying to say
the change must come from up and be
brought
down and so for those who claim to
change the sabbath
they have a task that they cannot
accomplish because the change
must originate in heaven where the law
originated itself by the way when god
gave instructions for the building of
the tabernacle
the ark which contained the ten
commandments symbolized the throne of
god
which means god's own god's kingdom is
based
on law and that law is an expression of
righteousness
any tampering with god's law is a
tampering with his kingdom
that is why the issue is so serious a
change in god's law
is verily an attack on the kingdom of
god
for that change to be made since the
earthly tabernacle
was an example of the one in heaven to
change god's law you've got to go to the
ark in heaven
open it change the law there and then
bring it down
that cannot happen because no one can
move god off his throne
attempts were made human beings follow
man made laws
the seventh day sabbath is a divine law
sundays the sabbath is a man-made
institution
amen amen now i know you touched on this
in the first
i believe in the second also questions
right in the response you give
the question is the fifth question how
did the church transition to sunday
worship
was it the lord's name all right how did
the church transition good question
the jews always give the romans
headaches
and we understand why no one likes to be
conquered the jews of
all the peoples the romans conquered the
jews probably
were the most troublesome of all that
bless them for that
because no one likes to be conquered
they were always revolting
always rebelling there was a rebellion
in 135 i think the rebellion of barkoba
i think that's the name
because of that judaism was abolished or
banned or made illegal
by the roman power but even before that
under
emperor vespasian who i believe
reigned from 69 to 79 a few decades
after christ
he abolished the sanhedrin and the
priesthood
during his reign which means judaism was
very very unpopular among the romans
now under emperor hadrian who ran from
117 i believe 138 139
he made sabbath keeping illegal
with all these uh this opposition to
sabbath keeping from the roman powers
christian you see christians were
closely identified with jews
and for good reason christ was a jew all
the apostles were jews
the first converts to the teachings of
christ were jews who came out of judaism
to follow the new teachings of christ
and so christians were closely
associated with the jews particularly
because they were keeping the jewish
sabbath and i used the word jewish
sabbath carefully
the sabbath is god's sabbath not a
jewish sabbath
as time passed christians began to
figure out
what can we do to distance ourselves
from the jews so that the romans will
understand we are not jews we are
christians
they began keeping both days sunday and
saturday
now something else happened saturday
used to be a day of celebration the day
of feasting
that was transferred to sunday as a
celebration of the resurrection of
christ
and saturday was made a day of fasting
well all people loved to eat
so people began to observe sunday more
often than saturday because saturday
became
a day of misery and fasting and fasting
whereas sunday was a day of feasting and
celebration
so these things contributed to a gradual
it wasn't certain
it took centuries to a gradual movement
away from
saturday to sunday as a day of worship
and of course when constantine passes
law
in 321 when he became a christian
so-called
and began trying to act like a christian
it was easy then for christians to
follow the example of the emperor
but again it took several centuries for
there to be a
full-blown departure from the seven-day
sabbath but
god has always had people in remote
places keeping the sabbath
and the country of ethiopia is one such
example hundreds of years ago
where they kept at some point they kept
both the sabbath has never been
eradicated
because as long as god exists as creator
there will always be his lord jesus said
think not them come to destroy
the law or the prophets have not come to
destroy but to fulfill
for verily i say unto you till heaven
and earth pass
one john one tittle shall in no wise
pass from the law
and that means all ten so yes this is
the reasons why
sunday observance became popular because
of the conditions in society the roman
power
opposed to the jews the abolition of the
priesthood the abolition of the
sanhedrin
the making illegal of sabbath keeping
making sunday a feast day sabbath
a fast day all of these things
contributed to a
gradual shift away from god's day
to a man-made day of worship thank you
very much
pastor randiski now we have our sixth
question i will have sister denisha come
in and i have a
i have a request for those who are in
the who are participating if you can
post your questions in the question
section in the chat
and we'll definitely try to answer them
at the end of the questions we have post
posted all right thank you very much now
we're welcome sister denisha
thank you very much brother anthony for
making that request and thank you so
much elder skeet for just
breaking down uh the transition from
son from sabbath worship to sunday
worship and as he said it was a very
subtle and gradual transition and
history shows it to be true
yes so we've spoken about the transition
to sunday worship and the next question
is
what is the mark of the beast all right
the mark of the visa is identified as
sunday observance
but not currently
the mark of the beast will exist after a
law
is passed officially making sunday
the day of worship on a universal basis
i mean on a global basis
when that occurs and people have to make
choices now between
a clear man-made law and god's law
those who choose against god will then
have the mark of the beast
so no one has it now but the mark of the
beast is that
action which more than any other
establishes the power of the roman
church and this statement is found in
their writings
they have the power to change what god
has written they have the power to enact
laws and to change laws
and so the mark of the beast and god has
a mark ii which is the seventh-day
sabbath
are a sign or a token each power has a
mark
which is the way it always is the mark
of the beast
is the acceptance of man-made laws
above the law of god that's the mark of
the beast
and since that law has not yet been
passed no one yet has that
mark but faithful members
even now have the seal which is
faithfulness to god expressed through
obedience to his commandments including
the fourth
because the fourth commandment is a sign
between god and his people
so no one has the mark the beast now but
many have the scene of god
so the mark again the mark of the
observance
but no one has it yet it will only be
placed on people by their choice
when they willingly choose a man-made
day above god's sabbath on the basis of
a man-made law
that's when people will have the mark of
the beast
christ and satan revelation gives us two
cities jerusalem and babylon
revelation gives us uh two
two objects of worship satan
god it's a choice one or the other
of course we know sheep and goats wheat
and tears we know that but
revelation you either worship christ the
creator
or you worship the devil through human
agents
see when someone gives an offering to an
idol it's really given to the devil
because the idol is stone stone doesn't
know anything
and so the object of worship that does
not conform with god's system
is sin let me say that differently when
someone worships
contrary to god's prescription which is
his law
that worship is given to satan even
though the people may say
is being given to god if you read exodus
32 the chapter where they worship the
golden calf
aaron said in verse 6 tomorrow is a
feast to the lord that's what aaron said
the day was dedicated to god but they
were worshiping the devil that's oh
my god wanted to kill all of them and
moses had to intercede let me say it
again
when aaron and the others made that calf
aaron made proclamations saying tomorrow
is the feast of the lord
i believe that exodus 32 6. the fact it
was
proclaimed as a day of god did not make
it acceptable to god
because law breaking can never please
god the fact that someone says i keep
sending it
on a god does not mean god accepts it it
is no different
it must be it must conform with the law
of god
and god's law told the israelites do not
make images
do not bow them to them god's law tells
us the
seventh day is the sabbath not the first
the seventh day
and to keep sunday and say it is for god
your intentions may be right but your
action is wrong
and god in this mercy sends light such
as this program
to open people's eyes to teach them that
good intentions are not enough
we must worship god in accordance with
his
law his prescription and that is
condensed in the ten commandments and
that is done
through the power of jesus christ of
course
thank you very much for answering that
question and i think you also
touched on the sabbath being the seal of
god and the fact that many
persons many people i should say have
the seal of god
but the mark of the beast is not in for
no one has the mark of the beast
until legislation has been enforced
that's right so we have three questions
three questions in the chat and i think
you just touched on
this one is it wrong to worship on
sunday
that's the first question that someone
has posed that's a clever question
this is a very clever question worship
is a lifestyle
it is not an event let me say that again
worship
is a lifestyle sabbath observance is an
event
which is an expression of worship i hope
i'm making myself clear
that what we're doing now is an act of
worship when the bible says whether
therefore ye
eat or drink or whatsoever you do do all
to the glory of god it clearly tells us
your whole lifestyle must be worshipped
diet is an expression of worship
dress is an expression of worship
worship
is living in constant acknowledgement of
who god is
and what my responsibility and duty to
him is unto my fellow human being
now so we worship god seven days a week
the question isn't can i worship on
sunday or monday or thursday
the question is which day is blessed
that's the question
and the day god blessed and hallowed and
set apart for special worship is the
seventh day saturday
not sunday so yes you can go to church
on the sunday you go yes
but the seventh day sabbath is
saturday we have wednesday night prayer
meeting
that doesn't
amen thank you so much for that the next
question is if someone dies
without knowing the sabbath will they be
saved if they were loyal to the other
nine commandments
i don't want to be mathematical someone
whose life has been given
entirely to god cannot be lost
now no one knows everything jesus said
in john 15 22
if i had not come and spoken unto you he
had not had sin
paul writes in acts 17 verse 30 the
times of this ignorance god went at
so god understands ignorance and by the
way ignorance must have
two qualities one i didn't know two i
had no way of knowing
saying to someone don't tell me that is
not ignorance
for second peter chapter two verse five
for this they willingly are ignorant of
by the word of god the heavens were of
all there are many people and i have
experienced this who say
don't tell me i was conducting the
evangelistic series of the city of
detroit a very lovely lady came the
first night every night
i missed it a second night the second
week so i called
her on the job i haven't seen you she
said el skeet
i can't come back if i continue to sit
under that preaching i will have to make
a decision
so i'm not coming back but she was very
honest in her self-condemnation
very honest i am not coming back because
if i come i have to make a choice
this is the state of many people don't
tell me
i don't want to hear someone who dies in
genuine
ignorance but having served god you see
god deals with us
based on what we know if you know this
that's all god requires
if you know that that's what it requires
someone who passes away
whose life has been given to god but did
not know many things
cannot be lost the life of christ covers
that person
but no one who dies in willful
disobedience
can enter a land which is all obedience
it doesn't work
and by the way there's nothing there's
nothing suffering about ignorance god
does not like ignorance
john 17 3 this is life eternal that they
might
know thee the only true god and jesus
christ who thou has said
knowledge is an essential part of
salvation but where there is
genuine ignorance god in his mercy will
cover that person
through the life of jesus christ
amen thank you so much and you know we
have many questions that are coming in
the chat
um but someone has asked a question
which is our actual next question which
is
how should the sabbath be kept well the
bible gives this
sabbath be kept gives us some serious
clues
and after yes isaiah 58 13 and 14. let
me pray again father
as we continue answering questions give
us wisdom wisdom take god that the truth
may be properly represented
and you glorified and your people
blessed in jesus name i pray
amen if thou turn away thy foot from the
sabbath
from doing thy pleasure on my holy day
and call the sabbath a delight the holy
of the lord honorable and shall honor
him
not doing thine own ways not finding
their own pleasures nor speaking their
own words
and so we have don't do your own
activities
don't find your own pleasures don't
speak your own words which means
the bible is telling us our conversation
must be different on the sabbath
our activities must be different what we
consider delightful and pleasurable must
be different
there must be some holy pleasures that
are fit for the sabbath
and not the secular pleasures which we
have during the week which may be fine
for the week and so isaiah 50 13 14
gives us some clues now if you go to uh
the commandment itself exodus 28-11
remember the sabbath day to keep it holy
six days shalt thou
labor and do all thy work but the
seventh day is the sabbath of the lord
thy god in it
thou shalt not do any work so we know
avoid work
and anything related to work now since
you must be careful with your words
words proceed from how we think
our very thinking must change on the
sabbath
our thoughts must be occupied that which
is holy but this requires practice
and discipline yes i said discipline the
mind can be disciplined to focus on only
that which is holy on the seventh day
so that i do not sit at home or in the
church view on sabbath
thinking of the office work waiting for
me on monday or sunday
this is not south of keeping so sabbath
keeping is that
careful effort to make sure that in
speech in
action and thinking in all that i do i
am reflecting my awareness of the
extreme holiness of this day and i use
the word extreme because the holiness of
the sabbath
is the holiness of god the bible says
the law and the commandment is holy
just and good what is that holiness the
holiness of god and the holiness of god
is present in the sabbath day
commandment
as it is not in other days the other
days are not holy they're secular i'm
not saying they curse
they're just not holy the seventh day is
holy
the words holy hallowed and blessed are
used
only with respect to the fourth
commandment now
keeping this in mind recognizing who the
creator is
we guard our behavior on this day
when i was a little boy and ellen white
tells us to do this we would cover we
would turn magazines over so you
couldn't see the cover page
we turned them down because what you see
can affect your thinking
we would put a a sort of a towel to
cover the television screen we would do
that
remove your site anything that would he
would do that as children we were taught
to do that
we had to get our clothes ready on
friday your shoes polished we did all of
that
because that day is so serious god is
assigned an entire day of preparation
now that tells you
how serious that day is in the sight of
god he is assigned an entire day called
the preparation day
now that day is not holy but the sabbath
has a day
attached to it called preparation day
and so when you keep all of this in mind
you realize
everything on that day must be an
expression
of holy behavior which flows from holy
thinking
which is possible by keeping the mind on
a holy god
and you do that by going to the holy
word
amen thank you so much members of the
church must be taught
how to keep the sabbath let me digress a
little bit
i'm not sure what time it is let me
check my oh just four minutes left can i
have 10 more minutes
yes you can take as much time as you'd
like i'll escape okay
thank you on the issue of sabbath
keeping the law is righteousness all the
commandments of righteousness we're told
in psalm 119 verse 172 i think it is
verse 144 and verse 141
now 142. now righteousness is something
that must be taught it is not something
that
just happens because you're sitting in a
church listen to second timothy chapter
3 verse 16
all scripture is given by inspiration of
god
and is profitable for doctrine for
reproof
for correction and for instruction
in righteousness righteousness is some
it is not simply a quality of god
which it is but it is a lifestyle it's a
way of behaving
it's a way of speaking it's a way of
thinking and the bible says
it has to be taught listen to christ
matthew 28 18 to 20
and jesus came and spake unto them
saying all
power is given unto me in heaven and in
earth boy
therefore and teach all nations
baptizing them in the name of the father
and of the son and of the holy ghost
teaching them to observe
what does that mean people must be
taught how to obey
teaching them to observe all things
whatsoever i have commanded you
and all that god has commanded us is
summed up in the ten commandments
because the bible says
ecclesiastes 12 13 this is the whole
duty of man from commandment 1
to commandment 10 members need to be
taught how to obey god how to obey the
second commandment not to have idols
how to obey the sixth not to kill how to
obey the sabbath commandment to keep it
holy
because god made it holy but you must
keep it holy
and the question must be answered how
do i keep it holy i know how god made it
holy
but how do i keep it holy of the bible
plus the blessed counsel from ellen
white gives us a lot of information
and church leaders should make it the
business to regularly instruct the
church
in how to keep the sabbath holy because
my guess is without benefit of a survey
millions of advertisers have no clue how
to keep the sabbath holy other than
don't go to work
and there's more this happens keeping
and don't go to work because if don't go
to work is that worth keeping
every unemployed person is a sabbath
keeper
and that's not the case
all right thank you for that
yes yes in fact the other part of the
question that the person asked was
how does a person keep from being bored
so what do we do
after worship is over this is the other
part of the question
forgive me for laughing you see
someone who loves basketball is never
bored by basketball
are you with me someone who loves
football is not
bored by football a christian who's
bored with a holy activity
then my question has to be wait a minute
wait a minute
how can you be bored with something that
is
naturally the converted person
the study of the word of god changes our
tastes
let me say that again the study of the
word of god
changes our tastes changes how we think
changes how we respond to spiritual
requirements
so that boredom goes out the window when
we have the word of god
when we have access to the materials of
hell and white when we have access to
fellowship one with the other to
encourage one another
when we have nature all around us
because god is expressed first through
christ
and his followers in the bible of course
nature was the first book before the
bible came along
so there are ample opportunities to
fight against boredom
but the cornerstone against spiritual
boredom is a genuine
conversion to jesus christ and his
standard of righteousness a
genuine conversion will make bible study
church fellowship spiritual things your
greatest joy that's why jesus christ
when he was talking to the woman at the
well john chapter four she
went to the village to tell the good
news the disciples brought some food
in verse 31 of john 4 the bible says me
at the same time his disciples prayed
him saying master eat
they knew he was hungry he said i have
meat to eat you know not off
he was so absorbed with trying to save
the woman that food meant little to him
you see
because his his mind was spiritual
everything was spiritual
when we have the mind of christ and that
has to be developed
spiritual things become a joy
there's no such thing as i've heard
people say what will i do in heaven or
the new world
never never die i'll be born sick no you
won't be born sick
you will not be bore sick in heaven it
will be your greatest joy
a total and a constant surrender of the
life to jesus
is the defense against boredom because
then spiritual things
become your spiritual joy that's why the
bible says of jesus i delight to do thy
will oh my god
yeah thy law is in my heart what's in
the heart is done
joyfully david said in psalm 119 verse
oh how love i thy law it is my
meditation
all the day i love the ten commandments
listen to ellen white the christ object
lessons phase 97 paragraph three
the man who attempts to keep the
commandments of god from a sense of
obligation merely because he's required
to do so
will never enter into the joy of
obedience
he does not obey when the commandments
of god are accounted a burden
because they cut across human
inclination
we may know that the life is not a
christian life
true obedience is the outworking of a
principle within
it springs from the love of
righteousness the love of the law of god
the essence of all righteousness is
loyalty to our redeemer
this will lead us to do right because it
is right because right doing is pleasing
to god
ask god to put love in your heart
for his law and for righteousness
but the bible is the most exciting book
to the person
whose mind has been changed there's no
such thing as boredom in christ
how can you be bored by the creator who
just spake
and the entire universe came how can
that be boring
amen thank you for that answer uh elder
skeet now i see
two persons have raised their hands on
iphone would you like to pose your
question now if you'd like to please
unmute yourself
okay i just realized i have to unmute so
let me
let me uh let me unmute you or ask you
to unmute
okay iphone please don't meet yourself
okay i'm not hearing from iphone
michelle thomas i see you also have your
hand raised
if you would like to pose your question
please do so now yes it's not a question
i'm so happy that i could be online with
east new york this is roger thomas
i'm happy that i can see randy skeek
once again i don't remember me
for a long time from uh from the airport
in
i guess indiana oh
yes yes yes yes yes you remember right
it was south bend oh yes oh yeah yes yes
yes
god bless you yes my comment is that uh
what god bless is a day because
because the thing it is and he called
his sabbath day because the reason why
he blessed the day is because
any people anybody could call any lady a
sabbath so he specifically said the
seventh day
and when you look at hebrews 4 and verse
it says that for if jesus has given them
rest
then would he not afterwards being
spoken of another day
so if the table was changed he would
have already spoken about it
that's right okay thank you thank you so
much
um brother thomas and i just want to let
everyone know this is not east new york
sda church's program um this
is so i i don't want any confusion this
is
by god's grace thank god the word
inspired is something that the lord
inspired me with about five years ago
which started as a blog
um i see iphone you had unmuted do you
have a question and please let's limit
our comments to questions if
so that we don't uh expend any time
iphone do you have a question that you
would like to pose
my question is is it okay school on
an eight year walk on the sabbath it is
absolutely okay to go on a nature walk
listen to uh um
psalm 19 verse 1 the heavens declare the
glory of god and the firmament truth is
handiwork
now listen to isaiah 6 3 the whole earth
is full of his glory
yes in you can go on a nature walk in
search of the fingerprint and the
footprint of god in creation
it is god who made the vegetation god
made the birds on day five
god separated dry land from the water on
day two it is god who made everything
and so you go on the nature walk
in search of evidence of god in a flower
in a tree in a fruit one of the best
things that can be done particularly
where children are
present is to go on a nature walk but
your motivation
has to be right christ object lessons
page 316 paragraph two
every act is judged by the motives that
prompted
god judges why did you go it must be
to search for god just to experience
god's creation
and by faith to see the evidence of god
in the things that he has made the same
way an artist has a style
creation has the style of god and the
eye of faith
will reveal that to us yes nature walks
are excellent
thank you very much you're very welcome
you enjoy a lot of your summons
these were my favorite casters ah god
bless you thank you for loving god's
word may the lord bless you and make you
a blessing to others god bless you and
your family
thank you so much you're welcome
amen amen thank you so much for that
question
my sister and elder skeet now i know you
asked for 10 more minutes and we have
reached that 10-minute mark
um there are more questions there are
more questions would you like
to take a few more i'll take a few more
okay so this next question
is will all sabbath keepers enter the
kingdom of heaven
why or why not let me pray again father
in heaven as we continue answering
questions
let your spirit direct his father
especially direct me
in jesus name i pray amen will all
sabbath keepers enter heaven all
obedient people will enter heaven
all obedient people listen to revelation
22 14
blessed are they that do his
commandments that they may have right to
the tree of life
and may enter into the gates into the
city why was adam thrown out
because he disobeyed romans 5 19 was by
one man's
disobedience many were made sinners so
by the obedience of one child may be
made righteous
obedience through christ is our
admission
into heaven let me say that differently
we we reclaim
the right that adam lost when adam seen
he
lost his right to the tree of life he
was put out
when we obey according to the bible you
can only obey through christ
we reclaim the right that adam lost and
that right is reclaimed through christ
obedience is the foundation
of all god's blessings and the greatest
blessing of course is an eternal life
with jesus christ without any end
so all obedient people will
enter the kingdom of god as i said
earlier if all you know
is this and you were faithful there is
a place for you in god's kingdom but for
those who are
willfully ignorant there is no place
amen thank you very much thank you very
much
um the next question is and and i guess
also just to clarify the i guess the
question was asking
if we keep the sabbath does that
guarantee that we're going to heaven
submission to christ stay let's go to
john 15 let's see something that's very
very critical when it comes to our
relationship with christ
john 15 from verse 4 abide in me
and i in you as the branch channeled
barefoot of itself
accepted abide in the vine no more can
ye
except you abide in me verse 5 i am the
vine you're the branches
he that the bite is in me and i in him
the same bringeth forth much fruit for
without me he can do nothing let's go to
verse 7.
if he abided me and my words abiding you
we shall ask what you will
and it shall be done unto you verse 9 as
the father have loved me so have i loved
you continue ye in my love
the word continue means abide verse 10
if you keep my commandments you shall
abide in my love
even as i have kept my father's
commandments and abide in his love
from verses 1 to 10 or 11 we have abide
about
10 times jesus says in matthew 24 14 i
believe it is
he that endures to the end of verse 13
the same shall be saved there must be a
staying in christ you see a staying
faith and works page 100 paragraph one
god
requires the entire surrender of the
heart in order for justification to take
place
and in order for men to retain
justification
there must be continual obedience
through active living faith that works
by love and purifies the soul
and so there's the coming to christ and
there's the staying in christ
a lot of people come to christ and they
think that's it once they've always
saved no no
they must be faithful obedience through
the power of christ and we must love
christ the more than we love our own
lives
and so the key is total surrender
our high calling page 215 paragraph two
i believe it is hello white rice
genuine conversion is needed not once in
years but daily
this is the life that we must live and
the power to live that christ
is the power that life is the power of
christ
amen thank you very much elder skeet we
are getting
so many questions that are coming in
someone has asked
i i'm i'm someone has asked so we spoke
about the nature walk
someone has asked is it okay um to go
swimming
or go on a beach on sabbath no you see
i have heard that before they also go
fishing what is your motive for that
you see when in doubt don't do it when
doubt don't do it
why are you going swimming if there's a
question mark about that activity
because very often we say we're doing
things for god but we're really doing
them for ourselves
our underlying motive is self
gratification when there's a question
mark about an activity
it's best to avoid it whether it's
swimming
fishing or you know jumping out of an
airplane whatever it may be and people
try to
put it under the heading of i am in
nature well i'm in nature right now
sitting in this room in my house
if i'm in a bus i'm a nation because i'm
on the earth are you following me
and so we must be careful what is the
motive and very often
we don't know our true motives
swimming i would not classify
as the same thing as a nature walk but
i'm not god
but the person who asked that or any
person of a similar mind
must ask himself or herself what is my
real motive
am i pursuing my joy or am i trying to
learn a little more about god by
observing the tree and the animals of
the sky and the seas
amen amen and um this next question
says there are a lot of denominations
that keep the sabbath
what is the identifying mark that
confirms that
seventh-day adventist or seven-day
adventism is god's remnant church
very good question revelation 12 17
and the dragon was rocked let me pray
again father this is a very important
question
give me the right words dear god please
in jesus name
amen and the dragon was wrath with the
woman
and went to make war with the remnant of
a seed which keep the commandments of
god and have the testimony of jesus
christ
that is a unidentified mark of the
remnant church the testimony of jesus
christ
which is the spirit of prophecy
according to revelation 19 verse 10
and you compare that with chapter 22
verse 9.
the testimony of the presence of the
prophetic voice in that church
is one of the identifying marks i'll
tell you something else that's an
identifying mark
listen to jesus matthew 28 18-20
and jesus came and spake unto them
saying all power is given unto me in
heaven and
earth go ye therefore and teach all
nations christ sent the disciples to all
nations
so if we combine those identifying marks
the observance of the ten commandments
including the fourth
the presence of the prophetic voice
among that people and the presence of
that people
all over the world if you belong to a
church
a denomination that's only found in new
york and connecticut
how can that be god's remnant church
where it is not found
all over the world and one of the marks
of god's church is they will go to
all nations by the way
i may be digressing the only two
churches on the face of the earth that
come
close to satisfying that did identifying
mark
that's the same thing after this church
and the catholic church
there are in more nations more countries
than any other nation
you look at the two now
the catholic church may say and i'm not
picking on people i'm just looking at
denominations
well we are we're in so many nations yes
let's look at another qualifying mark
do you observe the commandments of god
and the answer is no
and you have to have all the marks not
just one the commandments of god
the prophetic voice in the church you
must be in all parts of the world
you must have the faith of jesus as well
and so we look for all not just one
so there's a church observing saturday
in the sense that they don't work
but do they see sabbath as the mark and
the seal of god
do they see the sabbath as the center of
god's law do they see the sabbath as the
commandment that
identified god's reign the universe
his title his right to rule do they see
the sabbath
as that as the highest of the ten
commandments how do they see the sabbath
is it simply a day to avoid work
but my main point is the church must
have all the identified marks not just
one
and by the way everyone who generally
keeps the sabbath
will have no problem with the other
march accepting the other marks
as they are presented because the
sabbath commandment
is the test commandment it was for the
israelites in the wilderness it will be
for god's people in the last days it's
the test commandment
anyone who genuinely keeps the sabbath
will do whatever else god says
amen amen now all this skeet you have to
let me know when to stop because
keep rolling in okay all right
so someone has asked and
i'm okay i'll ask this question first
many meetings occur
after the service on sabbath for example
planning
for a pathfinder event or planning for
women's ministry event
is this okay
god is a good god since the nation all
those listening
god is so good let me give you three
examples of how good god is he made
seven days he gave us six
are you following me he said you take
six and do all you need to do i'll take
one
that's mine god says here's a hundred
dollars you keep 90 10 belong to me
god says here all the trees on the face
of the earth
i reserve only one you keep all the rest
now that's a good god god could have
taken the reverse position and told adam
only one tree is available to you all
the others are mine now that would have
been difficult for that
why am i saying that god has given us
six days to do all that we have to do
that does not belong on the sabbath why
do we try to cram
everything on the seventh day of the
holy day
one of the reasons is we are not willing
to give god some time during the week
we just barely give him the sabbath day
but we are not willing to give god
time during the week we act as if our
lives during the week are is ours
now our lives are ours but they're not
the god of the sabbath
is also the god of the entire week it is
he that preserves life
we must be willing to give god some time
during the week the same way a tithe has
an offering
the sabbath is specified there's no
argument there
how much time will i give god during the
week we can have our meetings on
different days people ask the world can
i have sex on the sabbath
you have six days
can i do this in the sabbath you have
six days
why pile everything on god's holy day
it is because i suspect we do not
appreciate the holiness of the day
which then takes us one step further
back to the holiness of the god
of the sabbath leave the sabbath
alone it is one day
you have six the sabbath pushes us to
practice
time management so it is not
contaminated
by these events that more properly
belong during the week
leave god's day alone do all you have to
do listen to the commander
six days shall thou labor and do all thy
work all the secular activities
acquire practice practicing marching by
the
pathfinders and the busy bees and
whomever do all of that in
six days leave my day
alone says god that's my response to
that
thank you thank you this next question
is
uh this week's sabbath school's lesson
touched on social kindness
uh doing acts of service on the sabbath
what is your response
uh to that um let me just read the last
phrase what is your response
uh to that if doing an act of service on
the sabbath
leads to making a purchase oh god frown
upon that
yeah the bible says jesus christ
all right let me
it's lawful to do good on the sabbath he
never said it's lawful to work
it's lawful to do good now disobedience
can never uh um what looks like a need
can never justify disobedience
because we're serving a god who's
capable of miraculous acts miraculous
acts let's remember that
disobedience can never be justified as
the basis for a good work on the sabbath
we serve a god who can work miraculously
we really do
when the ark was traveling on an ox cart
and it stumbled the cart stumbled azza
reached out to steady the ark god had
said
don't touch the ark
others intentions were good he wanted to
save the ark from falling and pressured
onto the ground
and god struck him dead not because god
is harsh but because god does not joke
when god says keep it holy he means
keep it holy and so i'm giving you the
principle
on the basis of that principle you can
decide what kind of good
social cause you will pursue on the
sabbath day we are to keep the day holy
we are to avoid secular activities on
god's day we must keep in mind if some
crisis arises
god is a god of miracles and god can
intervene
because god always honors obedience a
genuine sabbath keeper
looked for reasons to keep the sabbath
holy not for reasons
to compromise the holiness of the day
but jesus said it is lawful to do good
if your animal falls into the pit on the
sabbath pull it out
if a man falls in pull it out you're
driving to church in the winter
someone's in the ditch help the person
but thank you principle is it's lawful
to do good it is not lawful to work or
engage engaging sexual activities
amen now this next question and i said i
will ask it because this is a youth that
has asked this question
all right how was god created
how was god created i know the question
uh you can answer how was
god created god was not created god has
always been god is the source of life
i am the way the truth and the life
jesus said
you will not come to me you may have
life god himself
everything flows from god as a matter of
fact if you read isaiah 9
6 one of the names of jesus is the
everlasting father which means the
father of eternity
eternity flow from god that's a concept
that gives us a good concussion as we
try to think about it
god was not created all things flow from
god
listen to colossians 1 verse 16 for by
him were
all things created that are in heaven
and that out in earth
visible and invisible whether they be
thrones or dominions or principalities
or powers
all things were created by him and for
him verse 17
and he is before all things and by him
all things consist
four times we have the expression all
things if you say god was
created who created him god is god you
don't go further back than god
we cannot explain that fully but god
will reveal to us when we get to the
other side
god has always been there everything
comes from him by the way when i
father son holy ghost they were not
created they have always been there
and i'm glad amen amen
this question is how do we know that the
bible is the truth of god
because the bible's predictions are
absolutely reliable for a small example
daniel chapter 7 daniel chapter 7
predicted events
that occurred precisely as predicted in
the book of daniel daniel 2 and daniel 7
which is the the flaw of of nations
the babylonians in the time the book was
written the middle persians
the greeks and the romans and the
breaking of the roman empire into what
is now europe
as it was predicted in daniel 7 and
daniel 2
so it came to pass that's a simple but a
profound
example of the absolute reliability of
the the bible you take the writings of
luke and axe
luke was a medical doctor he was also a
historian modern historians who studied
the book of luke and acts
the books have looked at because the
same person wrote both they have
discovered
that all the persons all the places all
the events actually happen
on occur the bible is an absolutely
reliable book when it deals with any
subject it chooses to touch on
but is history absolutely reliable
archaeology has repeatedly
confirmed the statements made in the
bible the events in the bible the
personalities in the bible
the bible is the most reliable book you
can read when read under the guidance of
the spirit of god
there is no basis for doubting the
reliability of the bible
let me say this there are no mistakes in
the bible not doctrinal mistakes
mistakes lie in the mind of the sinner
the bible as god's word has no doctrinal
mistakes
amen amen and elder skeet i'll notice
the last question
all right hello um
[Music]
hello hello uh do you have a question
yes uh and it goes back to
it before you there's no kindness
um i am
a contractor and um
i get up on a sabbath morning to go to
church
and uh one called me to tell me
my house i have young children
it's 18 degrees um
and i have no heat no hot water
on a situation like that how do you deal
with it do you tell them well
okay it's my sabbath i'll deal with that
after sabbath
and how do you deal with the situation
like that
well we're dealing with a situation that
may lead to loss of life it's winter
there's no heat there's nothing
jesus said if your animal falls at the
pit the animal's life is a danger
pull it out if someone's about to help
the person you can't
charge the person but you're not to work
in the sample but it's an act of good
it's a good work that you're doing on
that day so it's not really work where
you earn money
it is an act of mercy you're performing
just like pulling an animal out of the
pit
it's an act of mercy someone says my
heat is down i'm freezing no hot water
little children
you go you help it's a good work
it's not a work that earns pay and if
you have to go to the store to purchase
material it's still okay now
that's where you have to talk to god
because there's a holy spirit who
directs and guides that's where you have
to talk to your god
father should i take this step or that
step
is there another way to fix this problem
without taking an
action that normally would be a
violation of the sabbath
you talk to god is there another way to
do this
so that i do not have to violate your
sabbath you put that to god and god will
direct you
okay thank you god bless you
thank you for that question now i'm
going to open the floor does anyone else
have a question that you would like to
pose
oh okay someone has yes i have a
question
go ahead my question is
um we assembly adventists have the six
days
and we'll do um should we go out there
on saturday
and do distribution of food or clothing
when we have the six days what should we
actually do on this sabbath as god
do we come that as good giving food is
good yes given our clothes is good of
course
but as you said or you suggested is it
possible to do it
on one of the days of the week
you see the sabbath must always be on
our minds it must
always be on our minds and by if when
that's the case it guides our choices
our decisions our behaviors on the six
days
am i conducting myself in such a way on
the six days that no violence or
is done to the sabbath can it be done
for between sunday and
friday and almost always the answer is
yes
you know david wanted to build the ark
that's a good thing not the art the
attempt the temple
god said no let all of it do it so the
fact that something looks good doesn't
mean that you have to do it
we seek god's guidance can i restrict
this thing to the six days
one of our problems generally is that
our very
low view of the holiness of the sabbath
we have a
long view of the holiness of god's
sabbath
which is directly a result of our lord
view of the holiness of god
anything that can be done in the six
days do it
it may call for sacrifice it may cause
some inconvenience
but calvary was inconvenient but jesus
went through it
amen obedience is a form of sacrifice
all right elder skeet you let me know
when you want me to ask the last
question
all right let's hear this one uh this
question is if people need to take buses
to get to church
is a bus driver who knows about the
sabbath and chooses to
to work doing wrong is the person riding
the bus
doing wrong by paying for the bus
okay
let me express what i said earlier
our motive must be how can i obey
not is there a way to get around this
commandment the question how can i obey
how this is what must drive us how can i
too often our question is
how can i get around this thing and once
we have that mentality we will find ways
to get around
because the carnal nature will produce
them
christian uh church members you know
elvis says before christ come we will go
back to primitive godliness
so that if i know there's a member in my
area who needs a ride
i arrange to have that person picked the
church can make arrangements to have
people picked up but very often guys one
person doesn't care about the other once
i get the church that's my business you
find your way
a church family is a family one cares
about the other literally
that's why paul uses the body to refer
to the church if the tour is hurting
i am hurting if you shoot me in my oh
you have shot me
church members should come together what
can we do to ensure that people have
transportation
so they do not have because it's not
only a matter of paying the bus
it is a matter of being in an
environment that is not conducive for
sabbath-keeping
you're hearing things you're seeing
things all of that must be considered
what can the church do well let me tell
you something when god's people come
together with the motivation what can we
do
to ensure that we obey god god makes a
way
but we must get away from well how can i
get around this and get around that we
must get away from that
what we do as a church family to make
sure
that church members get to church
without taking buses or trains
amen amen and and you know i there are
two more questions that i see
and i think you perhaps answered the
first
one saying is it okay to keep the
sabbath alone and forget
the other nine commandments no you can't
do that
genuine obedience is total submission to
god
the bible says ecclesiastes 12 13 the
commandments of god are the whole duty
of man
so if you ignore nine you're ignoring a
major part of your duty
the whole duty of man is obedience to
god's law
by the power of christ you cannot pick
and choose
because either one and disobey your
short disrespect for god
you know when thief breaks into your
house he doesn't have to break every
window he breaks one and he comes in
one broken window and the security of
your house is compromised
one broken commandment and you've
compromised the authority of god
in your own life god gave us 10 because
he wants 10 if he wanted 9 you would be
given 9.
god is very precise god told neiman
through elijah
dipped seven times if he dipped six he
would have gone home a leper he had to
dip
several god is precise and serious
and strict with god strict and love go
together very well
thank you thank you all the skeet now
someone has asked um
what if you go to a job like if you work
for a senior home i guess this is like
for the medical field
those that work in that realm is it okay
for them to
work on sabbath but not take the pay for
it
you're not supposed to work on cells
i don't know and how many languages i
should say that
we're not supposed to work on sabbath
now being a medical doctor or nurse is
not the basis for working because you
get time and a half or double time
we have counsel from loi medical mission
uh medical ministry page 216 paragraph
two
if the doctor or the nurse has to go in
only do that which is necessary
to ease suffering that's what she says
reserve everything else for the next for
the next day or
the next secular days only do what is
necessary to ease suffering
which is consistent with it is lawful to
do good on the sabbath and of course the
money must be given to the church
which very few people do so being a
doctor or nurse does not mean the
sabbath does not apply to you
because once you make an exemption for a
nurse or a doctor here comes the firemen
here comes the policeman here comes
electrician here comes the pilot
here comes everybody well i need an
exemption
none of the ten comes with an exemption
all right this next question says and
thank you for that
so should pastors not receive
honorariums for preaching on the sabbath
that's a very interesting question
should pastors not receive honorariums
for preaching on the sabbath
i've never heard that never thought of
it but it's a very good question now the
bible says
the laborer is worthy of his reward but
if preaching is considered
work you see when an elder preaches
is that work perhaps no now if a pastor
is
is hired by a conference he is already
being paid by a conference
there is no need for him to be paid by a
church to whom he goes to speak
you understand but work whether it's
preaching or whatever it may be
work must be avoided on the sabbath but
the church has to be shepherded on the
south
but if it applies to uh the conference
can very easily say we're paying you for
what you do between sunday and friday
we don't pay you for what you do on on
on the holy day
but we i still get back to the question
should a pastor receive an honorarium
for what he does on sabbath i've never
heard that i'll have to think about that
never heard it
now if you consider preaching work
then he shouldn't work on sabbath
thank you for that no work is to be done
on sabbath
no work do good yes
no work no compensation for work on
sabbath
amen amen now this question and thank
you for that this question says my local
sda hospital organization
holds five k so five kilometer walks on
the sabbath
tied to different diseases
well it's a seventh-day adventist
hospital organization
they all 5k walks in sabbath
i tell you god's people god's people
make me smile
why can't they hold it between sunday
and friday
leave god's sabbath alone
leave it alone
questionable activities for the week
if there's a question about it avoid it
you have
six days to walk 10 000 miles if you
choose
why do it on the sabbath
my policy is leave the sabbath
alone don't touch it you're not supposed
to touch the tide
don't touch it
let me just mute someone and then i will
allow you
okay dr taralong i see you would like to
pose your question you are free to do so
and pastor skeets i have a follow-up
question to the wonder of broken and
sabbath
yeah so i am a nurse if all the nurses
don't go to work and suffer
because it is work who will take care of
the patients
now you're looking at it you're looking
at obedience from man's point of view
not from god
if god calls you to obey him he will
deal with consequences
we must never look at this thing from
the perspective of people
even though people are involved but we
must always begin from the side of god
the bible tells us it's lawful to do
good on the sabbath yes there is
suffering yes
our prophet tells us only do that which
is necessary to ease suffering
and leave the rest you see when we when
we go and apply for
jobs we must tell employers very clearly
who we are
and what we stand for very often we
don't because if we do we may endanger
possible employment our employers must
know
right up front this is what i do
this is what i don't do because i'm a
seventh-day adventist
[Music]
and so if you're a nurse or doctor
whatever you are
god bless that profession luke was a
medical doctor
but it does not change the fourth
commandment
in it thou shalt not do any work
again alawite tells us do good
do good but leave unnecessary work for
other day
honor god's law
this is no joke total obedience to god
is not as widespread as some of us may
think there's no such thing as
convenient obedience
the highest expression of obedience is
calvary
that's what the bible says he became
obedient unto death even the death of
the cross
genuine obedience includes sacrifice
amen amen it's very sick i'm glad we're
having this discussion
one of the reasons people see the power
of god is because we don't obey god
amen thank you for that elder skeet now
this next question
kind of speaks to the one about the
honorariums it says
is it okay to pay singers or musicians
to play or sing
in church on the sabbath well if it's
wage earning
it's work
it's work in it thou shalt not do any
work
amen amen you see we
there must be principles on which we
stand one principle is
you cannot make an exemption for any one
of the ten commandments
you cannot do that once you do that
you open the floodgates to make
exemptions for all the other nine
so some man can argue well i live in a
country where they
uh ten times as many women as men so i'm
helping out society by having five wives
no
no no no we cannot make exemptions
for any one of the ten
amen amen now i'm not too sure how
related this question is to the sabbath
but someone has asked is it okay for an
sda to join the army
well okay so it's not related but you
know
in the army you have to deal with the
sabbath as far as
as far back as the 1860s the church had
a position
that is okay for members to join the
military but not in a combatant
um not as a bearing arms as a
non-combatant in other words
you go as a medic a chaplain some
area of service where you do not have to
shoot people and kill people
that's the position in a non-combatant
status yes
but also keep in mind when you're in the
army you don't belong to yourself
so you there's a risk involved by going
into the army
someone who cares about obeying god's
sabbath commandment
will try to avoid situations that make
sabbath keeping a difficulty
that goes to students you go to school
that knows nothing about god
because you think the school has a good
name is prestigious then exams are set
on sabbath and you take them
we must avoid situations that create
difficulty in obeying god especially the
sabbath commandment
avoid them
many people sacrifice for a degree
amen or the sabbath for god or the
sabbath for
some romantic partner we think of others
first we don't think of god first
amen and someone had posed this question
earlier on and i had responded to it but
someone said i heard brother skeet
saying that the sabbath was before
creation
uh what was before creation why was the
principle established then
the principle of the sabbath is the
recognition of who god is
now before this earth was created angels
existed lucifer existed long before
they were sin on this earth or this
earth was even made simple reasoning
if you go to genesis chapter 1 you read
verse 11 and god said let the earth
bring forth grass
the earth yielding trees the fruity
yielding fruit after his sky
vegetation made on the third day one of
the trees
made was the tree of the knowledge of
good and evil which means evil existed
before adam was made
because i was made on the sixth day the
tree of the knowledge of good and evil
on the third day
lucifer existed long before the universe
was made
uh the cosmos connected to this earth
they were angels they were archangels
they all existed unfollowed worlds
existed
that's why the sons of god shouted for
joy at creation
when they saw how god created this world
and the atmosphere connected to this
world they rejoice
so as long as there has been created
beings the sabbath principles existed
because
anything created depends upon god for
his continued existence
where does matter whether it's time
whether space
anything that exists exists by the power
of god
we just don't know about how big a god
deserves
amen amen and the recognition of god
as the one who sustains me that's the
sabbath principle the
day began with the creation of this
by the world that principle must go with
us sunday monday tuesday wednesday
thursday
so the sabbath principle must be
observed all during the week
the sabbath day is observed one day of
the week the sabbath
principle so when you're sitting on your
desk you're managing some big company
you're making two million dollars a day
you recognize god
deuteronomy 8 18 give you health to get
wealth
when you're doing whatever you're doing
you're running a successful business god
gave me the talent and the skill
so the dependent principle goes all
during the week
the day is the seventh day
amen thank you for that complete answer
and to my knowledge i believe we have
covered all questions that have been
asked
well let me run another one pops up yes
on
zoom facebook and youtube
all right let me share this with you
comment
obedience is a non-negotiable experience
with god
the power to obey is the very power of
the life of christ
in you jesus said in john 14 10 is the
father in need that does the work
then for us it must be the power of
christ in us with christ
in us doing the things of god become our
natural joy
and we do them even at the cost of life
and limb
because obedience is just a way of
pleasing god
first john 3 22 and whatsoever we ask we
receive of him because we keep his
commandments
and do those things that are pleasing in
his sight
you know if you do always ask the
question
how can i obey god avoid the question
how can i get around this command
whichever one it may be
may the lord bless you and always
remember all of god's promises
are based on obedience
may i make a short comment please
who is that this is a netsmart
all right go ahead dr the nurse
dr denise is the boss she'll tell you
yes denisha man
well go ahead you have started already
okay
i just want to say to eldest i like how
you are
firm in your answers and your belief you
sway not
to the right or to the left
amen perfect when you talk about god
take a straight path that's right
don't hammer don't no even if you're not
perfect yourself
but you're talking about a perfect god
straight back adam had simply obeyed god
we would not be in this situation now
but he disobeyed
and it was a small act just out of fruit
that's what vegetarians do but look at
the world today
obey him he split with god
amen amen amen god bless all those who
listened and i really mean that from
especially the youth and the young boys
and girls god bless you and
use you to advance his cause a lot of
trouble is coming upon us
tremendous trouble is coming very soon
we have to make our stand for god now a
lot of people who believe
i'll be faithful when the time of
trouble hits or the sunday law has
passed
the bible says in luke 16 10 he that is
faithful in that which is least
is faithful also in much it is
faithfulness in little things
that god judges us and determines how we
behave when the big thing hits
if you're not fearful now how can you be
faithful when the death penalty is
passed it does not work it makes no
sense
practice faithfulness now in little
things
when the big trials come you would have
practiced faithfulness
and you will be taken through by god god
bless you in all that you do
thank you doctor thank you very much
elder skeet for answering all of these
questions and even staying
46 minutes and change over time
may the lord continue to bless you and
your ministry
thank you all for your questions and
interaction and i pray that you left
here with a better understanding of the
sabbath and more so
of what god requires of us and who he is
his law
is love and we keep his commandments out
of an expression
of love and our faith to him so the
sabbath
really just embodies who god is and
honors him
as our creator and redeemer
um so we're coming down to the close of
this program and i had wanted to
put this file in the chat last year i
had done
a series on how the sabbath was changed
and um i put it all together in a pdf
and i just put it in the zoom chat so if
you would like to take a look at that
you can
and i invite all of you to come out god
willing
sabbath april 10 at 2 o'clock p.m
eastern standard time where we will be
having a question and answer with dr
walter vice
discussing victory over sin so can a
christian be perfect
uh does god require christians to be
perfect
what does that perfection uh require
of us um and it
god willing will be answering that
question so feel free to tune in then
and i realized i had actually missed
another question asking to explain
matthew 12 verses 1 to 5
god willing another time we will now
have our closing prayer by elder
selan gilbert oh and i forgot to thank
everyone that participated
thank you so much sister stacian for
starting us off with a poem
happy sabbath thank you brother robinson
altino for ministering so
powerfully amazing grace thank you
brother anthony ralph for assisting and
asking those questions to elder skeet
and elder gilbert thank you to advance
for doing the closing prayer
all over to you amen it was a
joy it was you know the psalmist said
the joy
of the lord is my strength
and as eldasquit spoke it just filled me
with
power and strength and confidence to
keep going
on it was uh very um
edifying and so we ate until we had
a lot to put aside for for another day
so even though as we are praying and i
thought my phone would cut out on me
it's
say the battery is very low but god kept
it
so let us pray which was a joy it was a
very very good time that we had here
today and we are never bored
on the sabbath when we are enjoying the
things of god amen
let us pray father in heaven we thank
you we
praise you we glorify you lord
we are so happy that we
were able to ask all these questions
to your servant elders keith i pray lord
that he will continue to protect
to guide to educate him and use him
in ways that he would not even think
about
but in ways when he reached to heaven he
would realize the thing that he did
in uh educating and helping save so many
lives
bless him bless us all thank you for all
the participants
those who ask the question uh be with us
and
keep us faithful keep us faithful
and thank you in jesus name i pray with
thanksgiving
amen amen
amen amen thank you so much elder
gilbert and i should say i'm not a
doctor yet i am in my
third year out of a seven year bsmd
program
um so i am studying studying to be a
medical doctor
and i just want to close out with this
song i was supposed to play this song at
the beginning of the program
and i had forgot um but here it is this
is amazing grace you heard brother
robinson altino
minister amazing grace on the piano but
hears it vocally
thank you all
[Music]
how sweet the sound
that saved
like me
[Music]
i once was lost
but now found
was blind
but now
[Music]
i
it was
my heart to
fear and
grace my
fears
how precious how
precious did that grace
[Applause]
[Music]
toils
i have already
it was god's grace
and grace
[Music]
when we
is
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
man
everyone that is the end of our program
thank you so much for tuning in and i
pray that the lord grant you a rich
blessing and favor and that we all would
leave here with the greater
not only understanding of the sabbath
but a greater love for
god and his requirements for us that
they are
love um i pray that you are blessed and
once again
god willing i'll see you all april 10th
2 o'clock p.m eastern standard time as
we have a question and answer segment
with dr walter wife
discussing victory over sin
thank you all for tuning in and may god
bless you
thank you
you